ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we apologize for not doing
an episode last week
for easter but and i hate again i'm not
blaming ben i don't put it on ben but
ben does a thing every year with his
family
where they do like a recreation
of uh
easter where
they do they recreate the resurrection
of christ
and it was ben's turn this year to kind
of go down and be christ and his mother
said even though you work
for jews i want you to come down
she thinks i'm jewish the woman thinks
i'm jewish just because i have um i have
a mortgage
and she said you just have to
you have to play jesus this year
and they do a whole thing in the yard
and they speak in tongues
and they have like it's they don't have
the money to really
recreate a cave so ben just emerges from
a shed in the back of the yard and they
start chanting and so we didn't want to
ruin that because it's a family ritual
and you know i'm not close with my
family so i can't really judge other
people that are you know so when ben you
know and i've known of this and he's
talked to me about it
and uh
he said i have to go down it's it's my
uh chance to be jesus now last year his
sister was gonna be jesus she fell
asleep in the shed because she was drunk
and people's faith was literally being
tested they're banging on the shed get
up you drunk get up you [ __ ]
she forgot she was even in an easter
pageant or whatever you want to call
this so she grabs a gun and runs out of
the shed firing wildly
they wanted to avoid that this year
by having ben go back
sleepy little ben
with his little leather boots he wears
now because he's paid
and they wanted little leather boot ben
to walk out calmly and serenely out of
the shad pretending to be jesus so they
could all chant
uh and then eat peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches or whatever they eat it
doesn't matter
uh so that's why we didn't have an
episode if you want to know the truth
that's the fact
we're here in austin texas which has had
two days of sun in the last 20 days
and we'll have three days of sun in the
next 15 days this is the climate
um
and everyone here that you talk to of
course
has stockholm syndrome and before you
even bring it up
they go yeah it's never rain this much
it's never rain before and and it's just
i've now been here on and off
for uh over a year and all it does is
rain all it does is rain
um
and you know so we're thinking i got a
house here
i don't know what i'm gonna do with it
and
i've been a little depressed because i
you know we we finished it
me and ben like the property brothers
did a really good job ben don't you
think we did a great job i think we did
an amazing job we did an amazing job
renovating this home we did a kitchen a
bathroom did the living room we chose
all of the finishes we excelled
at
at uh home renovation it was kind of
like now obviously we're not gonna flip
it
because you know
you know you gotta wait right the
market's not great rates are going up
um
and there's nothing for us to do
uh here at the moment joe rogan is
opening a comedy club
that's
that'll be fun when that happens but
nothing is happening tomorrow
and
i don't know what i'm gonna do i'm not
gonna live here really i mean i'm on the
road a lot
but
i think
and this is probably the best
outcome
for this
we are going to
open up
an airbnb
for pigs
[Laughter]
the type of people
that visit austin texas pig women
that want to get drunk
and get stuffed with pulled pork or a
half flaccid [ __ ] in the backyard of my
[ __ ] house
we're gonna get one of those barrel hot
tubs
put it in the back
we're gonna get a few of those live
laugh love signs and you know
like you know i love eating good or
whatever the hell we'll put it on the
kitchen like or just a big sign that
says eat
[Laughter]
and these women are gonna flock here uh
for their bachelorette parties
because it's 20 minutes from the [ __ ]
wineries of texas
where if you like drinking vinegar
uh and the worst wine ever you can go to
the [ __ ] wine tour
of the texas hill country and many
piglets
who are about to get married come and
say let's do one last week out of
freedom and you know what freedom means
brisket nachos that's what freedom means
to the ladies brisket nachos does it
mean freedom to be an entrepreneur
it means freedom to shove your mouth
full of queso
and drink and fall down in the yard and
we are going to provide them that
opportunity we are going all in we might
do a thing
where like you bob for apples in the
fall and they can take their fat drunk
faces and dunk them in the tank how
about a dunk tank where you throw
something and then if you hit the target
they fall into the water i got a i got a
pool
it's perfect i mean it's a perfect
because i i can't sell
so and we've improved the property is
there any flaw in my logic here there is
a steady stream of disgusting
humanoids that come down here to live
out some fantasy they go into austin
they blow coke up their nose they give
their valves a real [ __ ] run for the
money they go down there they [ __ ]
listen to some heroin addicts scream at
the top of his lungs while he clumsily
plays a guitar with hands better suited
to hitting his wife
why not provide them a place of peace
and tranquility two acres three bedrooms
three baths newly renovated big fridge
guest house
guest house gonna be renovated one
bedroom one bath 750 square foot guest
house 2300 square foot main house two
acres of texas hill country greenery
pool
that's right
get [ __ ] up drink some hard cider and
get in that pool piglet it's worth the
money
that's what we're gonna do now i've been
kicked off airbnb so we're gonna have to
do it
maybe in my fat assistant's name
who and she will know what these women
want
she will know what these beasts want
what do these beasts want
she'll know
she'll get it she'll immediately be able
to she's a consultant will make her a
consultant where she can come in and
tell me
here is what the modern pig wants
when she's on her bachelorette party
this is what she needs
she needs uh i think we gotta make it
fun for them
there needs to be more activities in the
backyard you know
more like carnival games for them
what about like a big tic-tac-toe
you know something like that because
they are beasts and they are of limited
uh you know obviously they're completely
uncultured and uh their their mental
capacity is shall we say diminished that
being said they would like simple games
for them to play right games that fat
women could excel at
like like something that fat women
really like to do now the kitchen is not
that big
this is a problem so we're going to
imagine that there's not going to be a
ton of cooking done right so we got to
make sure that like there's ample
opportunity for them to store things
they will later eat
because they're not going to be i mean
these are not the types of women that go
in and go like let's cook some salmon
right they don't do that these are the
types of women i mean listen and i'm not
even trying to be disrespectful
is it completely inappropriate to have a
trough
to have a trough
where these pig women
can get on their knees give them knee
pads we don't want them sky their knees
are ready work hard give them knee pads
they can get on their knees
and put their faces in the trough
because you remember it's one weekend
before they get married and change this
behavior completely you see because
after they get married they're gonna you
know they're gonna get on the peloton
and start reading books but just give
them one more weekend of fat [ __ ]
pleasure
one more weekend
and they all want to meet guys you know
they want to they want to have a nice
story maybe not the bride let's hope
she's classy enough to keep a [ __ ] out
of her mouth a couple of nights before
she gets married right but maybe not but
her fat friends are gonna want some
freshmen at ut
to [ __ ] pork them or something which
i completely relate to
and
they're gonna want
but i'm i'm rich and have a little bit
of fame so sometimes that comes a bit
easier to me but they're going to do
what they're going to do right they're
going to get drunk at around 3 a.m
they're going to find some guy to bar
and rape them because it is socially
acceptable and it's getting back and he
he's not gonna care it's gonna be fun
for him and it's a story
and so what and i'm just we're driving
around now we're looking at all these
deer there's so many [ __ ] deer um
and these piglets are one they're gonna
want to get [ __ ] and my only issue
with doing the airbnb is that the
cleaning crew
that i'm gonna have to employ is gonna
be like the same people who cleaned up
gitmo after the torture
you know like after the torture sessions
when they came in to like wipe the sweat
and blood off the floor
they're gonna i'm gonna have to hire the
same people to come in here after one of
these pinatas was blown up
by some old drunk dad who she kidnapped
at 3 a.m in austin and drove him 25
minutes to my patch of dirt in
hicksville who cares nowhere vil
i'm just saying ben am i wrong about any
of this or is this the direction i
should head in the activities you're on
point they would love a big
board in the backyard that's right like
they have on cruise ships because you
don't move much with that that's right
you have a chocolate fountain that they
could fill up with you set when they
walk in they see the chocolate fountain
and then the chocolate they they can
melt next to it with marshmallows if
if we get a chocolate fountain
for these manatees
[Laughter]
i am telling i'll quit co i will make
enough money that i will never
have to work again now let me ask you a
question i didn't where would you buy a
chocolate fountain
oh you mean like a little one yes they
sell them yes that you plug in i think
we need the types of ones they use at
catering halls like the big ones
no i think i have to spend 10 grand
because we're talking five to six
beasts
i'm i'm talking about a chevy suburban
that's tight
a chevy suburban that rides like a prius
skin to skin
those women are gonna get out they're
gonna see it they're gonna go oh my god
it's beautiful
their voices are deep it's beautiful
cara
we're so happy you're getting married
so here's what goes on tomorrow we have
the wine
tonight we eat
[Laughter]
i've yelped four of the best barbecue
restaurants in town i say each one of us
maybe we should do a scavenger hunt
should we do a scavenger hunt for them
they're like things like that and we
could just leave
you know
you know like uh
parts of a cow around the yard
and they could discover them and then
eat them
i love athletic greens i'm telling you
right now we started them they make you
feel healthy they're great it's really
important i'm telling you right now ag-1
is great it is huge with one delicious
scoop of ag1 you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole foods
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right the special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging all these
things i'm telling you right now i i
love it why do you love it you know why
we love it
because it's a better way to start your
day than coffee right because you go in
there you get energy you get all your
nutrients it's easy it's a scoop it's
not a problem people usually take some
toward uh some sort of multivitamin it's
important to choose one with high
quality ingredients that your body will
actually absorb ag-1 is a small micro
habit with big benefits it's one thing
you can do every single day to take care
of yourself your subscription comes with
a year's supply of vitamin d which is so
important to add in these winter months
uh when you don't get as much sunlight
athletic greens was created when the
founder experienced a ton of gut health
issues and ended up on a complicated
supplement routine to recover it cost
him 100 a day athletic greens is much
more affordable than that and you'll see
the results immediately right now it's
time to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop with a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
to make it easy athletic koreans is
going to give you a free one year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
tim dillon again that's athletic
athleticgreens.com tim dillon to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
i am starting this because we have a lot
of probiotic issues
and because we travel all the time and
sometimes we're eating shitty food but
this is really going to turn things
around for us just go to athletic
queens.com tim dillon i've already
started this and it's amazing how does
it work for you
everyone loves it
athleticgreens.com tim dillon that's
athleticqueens.com tim dillon
i've stayed enough airbnb's and you know
airbnb is really taking a chunk out of
the business of hotels now because me
and my opener the funny sam talent who
you should follow we've been staying at
a lot of
uh you know we've done some nicer hotels
on this leg of the trip you know because
it's over the the tour is ending
um
and we've stayed at a few ritz carltons
and
ritz carlton
has given up completely like when i was
growing up it was the hotel
and
now
they just they just want to build like
residences where people live
and they don't care about the hotels
anymore but they're still banging you
out
over a thousand bucks a night
to stay there and now the ritz is owned
by marriott the saint regis
was also just bought by marriott
so now every
[ __ ]
like high-end hotel chain
in america
is slowly
becoming a marriott
so why not
you know people are opting for more
privacy they're going [ __ ] it let's just
do an airbnb
because you know nobody's doing anything
good at these hotels anymore the room
service is [ __ ]
i mean it's it's sad to watch these i
mean i like marriotts when i was a kid
because there was a novelty
to leaving your home and staying over
somewhere else and getting the room
service and but now
you know
these hotels are becoming methadone
clinics you know you have all these
tattooed fat people
wandering around not even classy fat
people like myself like pink fat
cherubic people i'm talking about like
disgusting working class tattooed prison
chefs really just wandering around these
properties it's grotesque but that's
what i will be creating a perfect
private serene oasis for wayward women
that are looking to have one last couple
of nights afraid now did your wife have
a bachelorette party she did yes where
did she go she she did the classic they
did the wine they do it they go to a
winery one night see your wife is a
classy broad but let's be honest some of
her friends is that's not the case
now you don't have to comment it just is
what it is
your wife's a classy broad but i get it
when you have friends
that want a certain thing you go do that
because they're planning it right of
course they're gonna they're gonna plan
it and where do you go you go to the
texas wineries because that's what texas
is known for wine
going and drinking wine
that's what texas is known for
getting a nice [ __ ] bordeaux
so what uh what region is this wine from
tuscola
this is red from abilene
yeah it makes a lot of sense but i mean
anyway
sam you could drive us other places
sam is is driving us in the car because
we can't do it in the house because
there's too much account we're nowhere
near a studio we'll be back in the
studio when the tour ends
uh in australia i know i've said for two
years the tourist ending i'm like share
doing the farewell tour next week i'm
gonna upload on instagram i'm gonna be
like
tickets on sale tokyo seoul kuala lumpur
okinawa no we're done we're done there's
nothing left to do or say um
and we gotta we gotta we gotta do an
airbnb here i mean there's there's
nothing
and and i think
you know what really attracts these
people to a property they like nature or
they think they do
and they like the idea of like creating
memories and taking photos right isn't
this what they want to do when they go
somewhere they want to do like they want
instagramable moments
right yeah when they walk in they want
to see a couple of disposable cameras
that are included with their airbnb
package right is that true oh yeah
really they love stuff like that because
that's old school that's like 90s 2000s
like you know the click click click the
the wind-up stuff they love that uh you
could even what if i gave them a can of
creamed corn
[Laughter]
cause they're disgusting
that's why that's funny they're
literally disgusting
i'm telling right now they should run
the other way from the camera they
should see a camera and look at it like
a jew in the 40s or a train these women
need to be nowhere near a camera
okay so what do they want they want uh
cameras when they walk in mm-hmm yeah
god forbid they're not recorded and they
probably want a uh like a mural that you
have set up on the property somewhere
because you have so much acreage that
they can take photos under especially if
they're gonna do uh like any
bachelorette photos types of types of
deals what if we marketed this to like
real pigs like if we were like
this ain't your mammy's airbnb like
we want you guys to have real fun here
get dirty
fill a kiddie pool with spaghettios and
finger [ __ ] each other
you only get married once or four or
five times
and you know we're gonna get second
weddings too
oh we're not just gonna get the first
wedding we're gonna get the girl she's
34 and she's trying it again
she's trying it again she's got a high
school aged kid who's been to juvie
multiple times
but this time it's gonna work because
she's married a man 40 years her senior
who's 70 years old but he's spry
and he's got a lot of money and by that
i mean 300 000
including assets and she just wants a
place to smoke weed
and get so high she dreams she's dead
let's have her come to my home
come to my home
come to my home and pretend your life
isn't real
come to my home
see friends you haven't seen for a while
and bond the only way you know how
drinking bottles of alcohol and
recalling the times you molested each
other
do it at my house come to my house
it's open the doors are open for you
to come to my
home i want you there in the backyard
bare foot
and we'll get some pregnant brides too
don't think we're not gonna get some
preggo brides and don't think if that
baby's formed they're gonna knock back a
few
i used to do coke with a woman named
michelle and she did coke nine months
pregnant she said don't worry it's
already formed
it's true i used to do coke with a
pregnant woman when i was 13 years old
with my friend shay she lived in
oceanside long island
and she was pregnant and she would do
lines of coke because she said i'm nine
months pregnant the baby is already
formed and she might have been right
because i agreed i said hey whatever
so if those that's the type of people i
want
renting my airbnb
people that are nine months pregnant
who will do a line of cocaine
because the baby inside of them is
already formed
how do we market it to them
the man who gave her the baby was
serving at three to five
he got out he was great they were fun
they were fun people
uh and we used to sit in their apartment
and do cocaine and it was not a nice
apartment but cocaine can make things
livable and then i would go home in my
bed and jerk off and lay there and wish
i was dead because coming down from coke
is horrible but you just jerk off and
stare at the ceiling how do we market my
airbnb to this caliber of human being
because you know they're gonna
masturbate let's imagine these these
women are not gonna get ass probably
maybe they will i'm hoping they do but
not everybody's gonna score it's only
human nature so i want these women just
as jessica kierson says going at
themselves like blasting she has a great
joke she goes blasting ac dc and going
at themselves with a jackhammer
that's the type of women i want
in my airbnb
this isn't an airbnb for like the like
you know
hot chick and her friends this is an
airbnb
for
a woman who
the bride
is
too hunch
and she's lost 30
[Laughter]
just to get married
[Laughter]
and her friends are like you look great
donna you look great and she's like
thank you
i've just been working so hard but this
weekend i'm gonna let loose because it's
a cheat weekend it's a and dude we got
it all what do we got in the area we got
sonic taco bell mcdonald's dairy queen
we got uh tcby we got schlotzki's
chickeny yeah chicken king right chicken
express people chicken
oh we got water bro oh you know they're
getting what whataburger
oh
you know these they're gonna get so
[ __ ] up
and they're just gonna go that's got a
water bag and you know one of them is
gonna be like white knuckling sobriety
because i have a dead they'll have a dd
they'll have one woman who got fired
from her job as a secretary for stealing
and
and she'll be in her third month of
sobriety and they'll be like are you
sure you can handle it denise and she'll
be like absolutely anything for you
girls i'm totally good i'm totally good
now she'll be crushing adderall in the
bathrooms but who cares she's going to
drive them to whataburger and man
they're going to go to town they're
going to go to [ __ ] towns they're
going to be as soon as they get to
whataburger it's like ukrainians across
the polish border it's
you're in the clear
they're gonna eat like they've never
eaten before and then ben you brought up
a good point we got to give them games
to play tic-tac-toe shuffleboard maybe
twisters fun but then they would hurt
themselves
horseshoes they like horseshoes
because a lot of those uh types of women
you're talking about they do the little
uh skirt the little dress and then they
do cowboy boots that's the move and the
boots goes up
a flowery dress and boots and scarred up
legs
scarred up legs from just the things
that bite you in the night
[Laughter]
and you know the husband is like uh
just some he's either there's two types
of husband
for these women right
lanky
meth out smells like gasoline
decent [ __ ]
decent [ __ ] a guy who's perpetually in a
state of getting it together and or
figuring it out
she will repeat those lines at nauseum
to her friends while not making eye
contact
he is getting it together or he is
figuring it out
the second type of guy will be me
fat and
gay
very gay who loves the feeling of a [ __ ]
hitting the back of his throat but feels
for whatever reason perhaps you know
he's inheriting a townhouse somewhere
worth eight
thousand dollars
uh he's gonna have to marry this big
pork chop because he can
he can think of men while he plunges his
penis into the vast chasm that is her
vagina and he will give her a child and
this child will be raised and it will be
stuffed like a turkey every day full of
chemicals and gmos and food he will be
her eating partner oh
mommy's being naughty again and she will
say that the child wants chicken nuggets
but damn well we know who really wants
nuggets and it's mommy
so he's just giving her a dog on two
legs that she can walk and drive
to food
uh places
and he will so there's two types of men
that she's marrying a guy who's gay
uh or a lanky guy who's probably
cheating on her
[ __ ] strippers
smells of gasoline
definitely lost a few months of his life
to queue
but
can put on a collared shirt and seem
like he could potentially
work his way up to management at
enterprise rent-a-car
like he feels like he could one day
possess the responsibility
to say it's in uh spot number eight
[Laughter]
thanks a lot we'll see you on thursday
before 12 p.m
now he's not ready for that yet in fact
he's months if not years away from that
but he possesses the ability to perhaps
eventually someday
work in management in a managerial
position at a car rental place
somewhere in a suburb outside of
jacksonville florida
so that's one of the guys put the uh
wipers on here so this gets brutal here
people just kill each other here
because they want to die
i mean ben that's the only that's the
only way this is ever so back to your
question about the marketing angle
behind it there's there's one big thing
you're gonna have to i think buy to
really sell this because on the airbnb
app there's going to be that one photo
that hooks them in right and i think you
need to get a windmill that you put in
the backyard or the front yard that we
have a picture of with the house in the
background they go crazy over windmills
for whatever reason because they like
wind because it cools them down
[Laughter]
to be fat in this country is to be in a
consistent state of having your sweat
frozen in a chili's by a very powerful
air conditioner
to be one of these women is to be
consistently
getting your sweat
frozen on your body
while in a very cold themed restaurant
while you suck back a margarita
that is the experience of being one of
these women and then you shuffle back to
your desk
at your job
where you do some type of medical
billing data entry fill in the blank
you dream
of pete davidson
or whoever the heartthrob of the moment
is or harry styles you dream of one day
harry styles with his perfectly pre pink
british [ __ ] climbing in your window
like peter pan and [ __ ] your fat corp
senseless
while you
while you enter information and then
call up someone who owes money for an
angiogram
but it's okay because come the weekend
you're gonna go to tim dillon's pig fest
you're gonna get five of your friends
and you're gonna go to the texas hill
country
and you're gonna drink wine
and let's just say you won't be counting
calories this weekend i'm gonna be
naughty this week and they'll say
let's get a few appetizers they'll say
let's get a few desserts so we can try
everything they'll say
but you know what they'll mean
and as those plates hit the table with
that [ __ ] stewed red onion that these
people consider culture when those tacos
hit the table and maybe some of them are
shrimp
oh we're being healthy
and then they have a chipotle or a lime
crema they're gonna go oh my god it's so
good
jackie thank you so much this is so much
fun we needed this i needed this i
needed that
how about this
i'm not even kidding whole fridge full
of choco tacos
hey ladies
we have brought the ice cream truck to
you
can't sleep don't worry about it have a
caramel apple empanada
need something to do while you're taking
this [ __ ] we got a good humor bar
what about an entire fridge stuffed and
i'm gonna be kidding here
stuffed with your favorite good humor
treats from when you first became fat
and developed unhealthy eating habits
and then never change them
i just i'm thinking this is the only way
to do it i can't live here it's a swamp
it's a hell
i can't do it
hair is so important so many people are
experiencing hair loss and the only way
to really effectively combat hair loss
is to keep the hair that you already
have okay
and the the place to do this is keeps
they offer a simple affordable
stress-free way to keep your hair they
have convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't even have to leave your home
24 7 care and support keeps as a network
of expert medical advisors prescribers
and care specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality it's
not expensive treatments start at 10 per
month and keeps offers generic versions
of the two fda approved medications to
prevent hair loss treatment plans are
affordable typically half the cost of
pharmacy prices yeah i mean i've had
family members you've had friends that
have used keeps they all love it it
really does work if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s
dot com
slash tim dillon to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p dot com slash tim dillon to get
your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon
they're a great supporter of the show
and they will support keeping the hair
on your head
people don't always realize that
physical symptoms like headaches teeth
grinding and even digestive issues it
can be indicators of stress and let's
not forget about doom scrolling sleeping
too little sleeping too much under
eating overeating i mean listen stress
is bad i get stressed out and i act out
in all kinds of ways and it's not
healthy what you need to do to manage
your stress is check out better help
better help is online
therapy that is great
i'm telling you right now it is
customized it offers video phone and
even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't even have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in person
therapy give it a try and see if online
therapy can help lower your stress i'm
telling you right now
you will not regret it you can start
communicating with a counselor in under
48 hours and if you do not
vibe with them you can just switch
counselors not a big deal
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and tim dylan show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com tim
d that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash tim d
my only question tim is do you also try
to include
do you advertise this to fat men as well
or is it just the just fat women yes fat
men but here's the thing with fat men
okay
fat men
a bachelorette party with fat man what
do they do they go to a strip club and
i've told this story before but like
we went my friend mike morris's uncle or
something i was getting married went to
some strip club there's really fat guy
in the limo and he's like well not good
in there i'm gonna be full these girls
are gonna be all over me he's a big fat
guy he fell asleep
in the limo we just went to the strip
club and we came out two hours later he
was still sleeping and then we just
dropped him off and he didn't even know
what happened
so
fat men i just don't think fat men
are the market like
they're just not the market
they're just not the market i i think
you got to go with because fat men
aren't trying to make a thing of it
they're not trying to make a thing of it
right
bachelor parties i don't know it's like
it's is it an airbnb thing for men i'm
sure it is but
i don't know what they do right
i went to one of my comic friends
bachelor parties you know the you know
uh
a friend of mine we went to like this
casino in atlantic city and this guy was
in the comic books and we all just lost
some money at gambling and went to the
buffet i mean it was sad right
women really want to make a night of it
guys do like booze cruises and stuff
what did you your bachelor party we
talked about it on the show you just got
together with some guys that smoked
cigars yeah yeah some guys were smoking
like gas station vape pins and we were
just like smoking cigarettes yeah yeah
sorry i missed that but
i apologize
i don't know where i was probably
working to keep the operation running
anyway um
but i i think it's really should be
marketed to women
it should be marketed to women who want
to have a fun weekend in the texas hill
country because it's affordable and it
provides them all of the things that
they need which is donuts
[ __ ] wine that tastes like balsamic
vinegar
and they can just slug it down and hope
to god that their lives are different
when they because everybody's looking
for like the weekend of a lifetime
and we got an urgent care a few blocks
away
just in case somebody saws a foot
cause there's gonna be injuries
they're gonna bleed
you know what i mean there's gonna be
injuries they're gonna get a little too
excited on the pool deck
somebody's gonna fall and injure
themselves now thankfully they're
padded most of these women are are
insulated
that being said i mean i think then
that's the only thing to do now
who
now i can't i now here's a dumb question
i can't
go on airbnb as a
host right i don't think no i don't
think so i don't think that's how that
works
uh but we can absolutely do it under a
company name i think no problem no
questions asked
really easy i mean why don't we just
literally call it like
fat [ __ ] weekend
and like blast lizzo
i mean let's mark it let's market it to
the fat baby that should be the headline
and they slide through photos of like
candy and jars the fridge full of treats
pictures of deer a windmill a cold pool
maybe an umbrella
tiki bar there's something about
this that excites me because i think i
can really market
to these people
and i've seen them i've seen them arrive
here
uh you know i've seen them walk down the
street in downtown austin
you know in nashville at least they have
that bicycle thing that they peddle what
is that called
uh i'm not sure but they have they have
them in austin too but they're more
popular in nashville i haven't seen them
in austin because no one can pedal
it's a pedal bar but no one can really
pedal so i've just seen these people
um these slumbering herds of cattle
that's one of our titles of one of our
episodes from years ago but i've seen
them you know these these uh you know
this uh
these like genetically altered farm
animals just ambling down the street
from one and you know that you can
always tell like a really fat one's like
what about this bar and she doesn't even
want to go there it's just the closest
one yeah
they're like the one we want to go just
down there she goes but this one looks
fine
and it's like katie you're just
150 pounds overweight
and you have a rash and you can't move
we don't want to go into this one
because it has a fish tank
but this is why austin is such a
uniquely horrible place
it's like disney world there's no worse
place
than a place that's dedicated solely to
making these memories
except the place is never worth it like
the place is never like people go to new
york to do that or paris or london
but those places can actually provide
some of the materials that you would
need to make a memory
because none of those cities are
distinctly
set up for you to make a memory
they just exist in a memorable fashion
but places like nashville and austin are
marketed and catered to bachelorette
parties people that are just trying and
it's such a basic [ __ ]
mentality to go to the place that
everybody else is going
right
to do the thing that everybody else does
there's nothing unique or or exciting
about following in the footsteps of
every other friend you have who you've
seen them on instagram with a [ __ ]
photo of themselves at a winery or a
photo of themselves
[ __ ] country line dancing or riding a
mechanical bull or you know oh my god
susan was [ __ ] wild this week there's
nothing unique
or i would be impressed if these women
went to auschwitz
or had a moment like have a moment
and understand that life's just not
about wedging your rib eye size steak
foot into a flip-flop
and going down the [ __ ] to the
[ __ ] uh honky tonks in nashville why
don't you go see some ruins go to the
scene of a war a genocide a crime
understand that life is serious and that
it will eventually end stop with this
immortality fantasy that these friends
aren't even your friends these people
that you're at this thing with they
barely like you you just grew up
together you're clinging to each other
because there's nothing else to cling to
so you're just clinging to each other
and there's a lot to cling to but that's
all you're doing you people aren't you
know bonding over anything but i mean
again i'm not going to write this all in
the airbnb uh thing i'm going to leave a
lot of it out i'm going to focus
primarily
on the fact that there's a pool you know
i mean
but that's how i think we get out
that's how i damn austin by giving it
one more piece of hell
[Laughter]
that's how i get back at this city i
give it back what it's given me
i
give it a spot
for fat
women
to come and pump up their economy
and make the city a little more
disgusting
i think that's the best way to do it
i'll feel good about that i'll sleep
tight
when i was a tour guide new york i
ruined the holidays of so many people
that just had enough money
to go to new york one time and they
hated me because instead of [ __ ]
talking about the empire state building
whatever horse [ __ ] they wanted to talk
about i talked about you know i don't
know human trafficking and penthouse
apartments you know fun [ __ ] and they
didn't like that but it made me feel
good because i was being true to myself
and if i as my last thing before i leave
austin turn my house into an airbnb for
fat disgusting women to terrorize this
city just a little more
i think me and you ben we've done the
right thing
but we've made it almost too nice yeah
it's too nice now we got to take some
stuff out almost i think
it's so
nice let me ask you a question
i could it's gonna cost a lot of money
to ship furniture right
uh where are you shipping it to the the
house i just bought on long island oh
okay
all of this works in long island dude
yeah all of it works yeah you could
actually tell you right now
all of it works in long island this
isn't amazing i oh my god
oh my god i understand now
all of it works in long island we fill
this house with beanbag chairs
inflatable furniture
we put outdoor paint on the walls so
they can vomit on it
you know what i mean
we ship all of this furniture to the
house i own on the east coast of the
united states
and then we just make this an adult
chuck e cheese
a dave and buster's for fat women we
fill the house with vibrators and
cadbury cream eggs and watch these
pieces of goo go nuts i'm telling you
yeah why not cotton candy machines the
whole thing oh yeah
popcorn
movie night
how about this they all sit in the
backyard while they're eating popcorn
and they're just blasting themselves
with dildos in the backyard
blasting themselves with dildos queefing
letting out a little [ __ ]
just blasting themselves watching porn
watching [ __ ]
interracial stepdad porn and
you know that's because by the way ben
everything we bought works even better
in the hamptons yeah because
which is i don't live there right but
right i live somewhere else cause it's a
little oceanic the vibe we got going
yeah it's a little nautical
yeah whatever ben but the point is
we get out we got to get out we got to
get out here we got to get out of this i
keep calling this local realtor and
going i'm listing it and then the next
egg i'm going to keep it and then the
next cigar i'm listing it and then the
next egg i'm going to keep it
this poor guy so i just go i'm gonna
keep it again but give me tickets to
your i said here's some free tickets to
my show i'm gonna keep it
but ben i'm thinking we ship all this
furniture
can we do it yeah i mean why just we can
do it yeah yeah we could do it man we
can do it
we can bring these pigs home
come home
your home in the pig heart for you
we've made a pig heart for you
is your friend getting married is your
life a bit harried i know life is scary
eat
just eat you pig
have a little bit of wine put on that
dress you swine just eat you pig
it's time for chocolates from belgium
that i bought at cvs
you won't know the difference hog
i'm telling you i think that's the move
i i really think that's the move sam do
you disagree great idea
thank you sam
[Laughter]
these [ __ ] billionaires they've got a
line on everything even inflation can't
touch them but i'm about to walk into
their eyes wide shut party and start
pulling off masks because now i know
their secret picasso basquiat banksy a
lot of these mofos are investing in mad
amounts of contemporary art why how
about 36 average historical price
appreciation when inflation is at 3
percent or outpacing the average total
return on the [ __ ] s p 500 for the
last 25 years now there's someone who
could beat them at their own game who's
making this art available to people like
us i'm talking about masterworks i've
mentioned before how i think this idea
is genius and a lot of you seem to agree
so i use my massive swinging influence
to get all of my listeners priority
access to skip their waitlist just go to
masterworks dot art
tim that's masterworks dot art slash tim
what's great about this ben is you can
invest
in a one of these
priceless
pieces of art except of course
everything has a price and they all go
up in value
so your returns not only outpace the s p
500 but they protect you from inflation
by putting your money to a place where
it can really work for you
as we've seen important regulation a
disclosures at masterworks dot io slash
cd
but in order to check this out go to
masterworks dot art tim that's
masterworks dot art slash tim i love
bird dogs they are pants where you don't
have to wear underwear
and if men need one thing right now
it's less of a barrier between
themselves and a story in the la times
so you have these bird dogs underwear
they are so
comfortable their shorts their underwear
they're everything they're the one thing
you have to remember when you leave the
house you don't have to put on layers
and all that stuff so you just go to
birddogs.com enter promo code tim dillon
and they'll throw in a free bird dog's
whistle football bird dogs are amazing
everyone i know
that wears bird dogs has a good life
there's not one person i know that wears
bird dogs that has any type of problem
not in their relationships personal life
health finances every single and i'm not
saying they guarantee this
and i wouldn't lie to you
every person i know just to give you an
example
my friend's father
doesn't wear bird dogs
and he was just taken out of his house
the fbi showed up and they took his
laptop because it was loaded with cp
that means child porn
he was a dark web pedophile and my
friend didn't even know and you know why
it's because he scoffed at the idea of
wearing bird dogs
now my friend his son
thank god didn't inherit a predilection
for dark web
child porn
he wears bird dogs he's got a lovely
wife they're getting married and they're
going to have beautiful babies and
they're all going to frolic around the
land but his father who doesn't wear
bird dogs is a dark web pedo who was
taken out of his house this is true
go to birddogs.com enter promo code tim
dillon and they'll throw in a free bird
dog's whistle
football
it's nice that's birddogs.com promo code
tim dillon and boom a free bird dogs
football with your pair of bird dogs you
will not take these things off i promise
you and that's really the test of
something if you don't take it off it's
good
i wear bird dogs ben wears bird dogs
everybody wears them everybody wears
them
you know and i mean listen when joe
rogan opens his comedy club i'll just
set up a tent
and i'll live in that
how about that
and you'll be like team mom he lives in
a tent mom he's smart
he's smart mom because
well here's the theme mom
here's the thing mom
it's like
you you realize mom that life is really
about
like
time
it's about time mom and a lot of people
mom they're like
afraid to put in the work to be who they
can be
but that's why tim lives in a tent mom
because he's freeing himself up from all
of those worries
and he's just becoming what he can be
which is a disgusting pig who lives in a
tent mom outside of my comedy club and
when i i knock on the tent and i go do
you want to perform and then he goes on
stage man and it's killer man
i think we've kind of i think we're i
think we're right here
i mean sam don't you think this stuff
works almost better on in on the east
coast give him the mic ben you've added
nothing yeah having uh helped you pick
some stuff out you have you have a great
eye thank you yeah that painting uh was
a big win yeah i think it's going to
look great on the east coast as ben did
say it is nautical
it is i mean it is it's a it's a
no it is but ben ben doesn't understand
when he says nautical people think
people think it means like lamps with
like fishing rope around it
ben doesn't understand that's not a tiki
bar i mean you just have a blue theme
this is a guy who pretended to be jesus
at his family's [ __ ]
[ __ ] shed resurrection that they do
every year
no i'm joking of course that that was
not true that's i have to say that you
know it's i don't want people to be
angry that's that is untrue they do not
do that
that's true right ben you don't do that
what did you do for easter what was your
easter tree i liked easter as a holiday
because my aunt who was on pills would
get very particular about like the
baskets and where they were being hidden
and she was like it was like her um
uh
insanity was really on full display on
easter because everyone was like hey
let's not take it too seriously you know
the kids are young you're hiding eggs
and
you know she just lose her mind she'd be
like god luck you know
because she was a drug addict
what uh what did you do for easter so
you wake up you go to church of course
as a good christian family and usually
wear like a tie so you dress up nicer
you have like a pink tie like a pink
easter time okay and then after church
all everybody goes out in a field next
to the church here's where by the way
folks i just want you to
i just want you to listen
i just want you to listen very quickly
because when in your mind i want you to
go how far away is this from tim's joke
from an hour ago because it's not going
to be that far away so now keep going
ben uh you left off uh in the field okay
so there's usually a field next to a
church in in west texas right so in the
field has already placed a bunch of
plastic eggs in like mesquite trees and
in bushes and in grass and in holes and
then everybody like at once sort of runs
and just goes like crazy looking for
eggs and if you're like a younger kid
usually a parent is with you and you're
putting eggs in a little basket and
they're usually filled with candies
little chocolate coins things like this
and what happens if you see you get the
most eggs you get to go see the pastor
in the back room
and you trade the eggs in for a little
salvation that's right
yeah
but i think that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna ship all of this for i mean
sometimes i don't even realize my plan
until it's underway yeah
and that's kind of the brilliance of it
that's the brilliance of it this is
going
out east
those chairs you have coming tomorrow
too those go to everything yeah
am i
everything yeah it all goes
it's over here
the game is over
george carlin would say the die has been
cast
um
oh yeah no we're go if we have to
furnish it we're going inflatable pool
furniture
outdoor furniture scotchgard everything
because oh yeah dude it's gonna it's
gonna smell like a curves
the gym for fat women
just big fat vulvas
but
that's all i can do that's all i can
really do this is the way to kind of get
out of here
and then my next move will be uh florida
have you heard of florida
and then i'll hate florida
four months five months into florida i
hate florida and then i'll turn my house
into a sober house
and move in a bunch of guys that i suck
off
so that i let them outside to meet up
with their friends to do the steps but
we know they're just blasting lines but
that's okay because they'll put their
big [ __ ] in my mouth every night
and i will
uh run a sober house in florida this is
what i should do i should move around
the country
and find that i'm miserable literally
everywhere
and then after that
decide what kind of
haunted house to turn my home into what
kind of horror should it be a halfway
house a halfway house for like wayward
men
white knuckling sobriety questioning
their sexuality in need of a few bucks
or
should it be an airbnb for fat
bachelorettes who just want to eat
edible cookie dough and get bombed on
[ __ ] wine in texas who knows i could
just move from place to place ruining
the country a little bit more making it
a little grosser a little more grotesque
destroying the landscape of this already
destroyed country a little bit at a time
one
city by one
city
put an airbnb for fat women in texas
put a [ __ ] methadone clinic in tampa
just look at the top 10 markets go into
nashville rent it to a bunch of [ __ ]
you know who knows capital rioters hey
boys we got a lot of space you do what
you think is necessary
just find the top 10 real estate markets
in america and then go into each one of
them and decide what exactly
they need like the up and coming markets
you know not la or new york are these
things i can't really afford but go to a
nashville go to places like this buy
something
hate it almost immediately and then
decide what to turn it into a religious
fundamentalist cult an airbnb for chubby
chubs
or a methadone clinic where i suck off
the guys uh so that they can get
privileges to go out and use drugs
i don't know
but i do know that that furniture is
getting on a truck and going east how
far is it from austin in new york not
that far uh about uh 18 hours i think
let me see let me google map here's the
deal man we actually
i mean it's going to cost money
but here's the deal
that furniture is a lot more expensive
in new york if i were to get it you know
probably yeah probably there's probably
bigger shortages up there
probably
this is a good idea ben am i wrong uh
let me see how far it is to there from
here
uh so it to new york city from right
here and they had two hours
and and why i had two hours it's it's
out east oh right
it's loading uh it says
27 hours
okay so it's like that's a drive so it's
farther than la
because i've done late here like seven
or eight times
what do you think we're talking five
grand
uh yeah probably we're gonna have to get
one of those pods again the pod storage
things yeah it's gotta be done well
it's great you know what here's what
we're going to do
give me the phone we're going to call
[ __ ] uh our [ __ ] business manager
okay because what's great about him and
this is what i really like about him is
that he has been able to hold down a job
being mentally [ __ ]
hey listen can you price me out
what it would cost to ship furniture
from austin to long island
okay yeah because we got a lot of
what
how much stuff 10 pieces
10 pieces
like a bedroom worth two bedrooms worth
like like a home
okay like a couch two chairs coffee
table two lamps two other chairs we got
it all and we're putting it
it to up hamptons and just plop it right
next to yours the austin house is
disgusting but here's the deal we got a
lot of great furniture but here's the
deal i'm not
we gotta get it out of this austin house
we're gonna the austin house is gonna be
turned into an airbnb for fat women
okay
we're turning it in eventually we're
turning it into an airbnb for very fat
bachelorettes we're catering to the
large woman who's unafraid to be herself
okay
all right so just pry some of that out
for me tomorrow thank you sir
for sure thank you
imagine getting the joy to represent me
i have such a great business
mind i have such a great business mind
that's why he's so happy to take my
calls i kid when i say he's mentally
[ __ ] he's great i don't think he's
mentally [ __ ] i think he's he lands
somewhere on the spectrum but not full
you know
you know he's not like wandering around
with a piece of felt
i wouldn't by the way i wouldn't let's
just say i wouldn't give him a piece of
felt and chance it you know what i mean
and if he had a piece it felt it would
be an nft he's cooked in that you know
uh timbercomedy.com there are no more
tickets to get so [ __ ] off who cares if
you didn't come i don't care i don't
want to do stand-up anymore i hate it i
hate everyone i'm kidding life is a
journey and a joy i enjoyed all the
shows every show was great but the
planes trains and automobiles these
hotels that marriott is ruining [ __ ] you
marriott
uh it's it's been a it's been tough it's
been tough the travel wares on you
that's why the podcast haven't been in
the studio in l.a we've been traveling
it's been it's been hard and i know you
people don't understand you go no that's
not hard
we're not going to do these things in a
hotel room or anything just get over it
get over it enough
um but we will be back in the studio
soon and there's tour is over really so
unless you live in australia
it's over if you live in australia it's
great oh we have vegas and reno coming
up who cares we'll probably put the
special out before then and i'll bomb
uh whatever this half of you will hate
the special probably that's fine too i
don't care uh the first show in denver
was ruined by a bunch of drunks so the
second show was good it's very very
solid but you should have seen it live
the point of comedy is to see it live no
special ever truly captures how funny
things are live comedy is meant to be
seen live or
in my airbnb
because we're going to have a projector
that you can watch while you're in the
pool we allow eating in the pool we
encourage eating in the pool and we're
gonna have a projector and you know what
we're gonna put on the food network so
you can watch people make food
as you eat it while you float in the
pool and you know why fat people love a
pool because it feels they feel
weightless they can't feel their
decisions
that's why they love it that's why a
fatty loves a pool and we have a pool
and we've got a lot of acreage
and you can graze
just like the castle you are
come to my airbnb come to my home
open the door it's your own willy wonka
chocolate factory and the golden tickets
all yours just press book on airbnb and
they'll be jars of peanut butter and
ashtrays
everything you heifers want
come to my home
come to my home just don't die there